sophia richie and scott disick are
heating things up in mexico but does
lionel approve plus is there an NSYNC
reunion brewing for the Superbowl
everyone Denny here I got a question for
you if your daughter was dating Scott
Disick would your reaction be because we
are learning more about what Lionel
Richie really thinks about his daughter
Sophia running around with Scott she's
19
he's 34 and he's also Scott Disick the
singing legend told Us Weekly of course
he's shocked and did not hold back
adding quote I'm scared to death are you
kidding me
now the rumored lovebirds were most
recently spotted enjoying a vacation in
Punta Mita Mexico and haven't been shy
about packing on the PDA in fact on
Monday the two were photographed
sneaking a steamy kiss all on a jet ski
and the two seemingly confirmed their
relationship just a couple weeks ago
locking lips once again while enjoying a
congratulations cake well it sounds like
Lionel doesn't exactly approve and
thankfully for him he is busy as a judge
on the new American Idol yesterday I
told you guys lying on a fellow judges
Katy Perry and Luke Bryan are already
bonded and here's some more proof
courtesy of Katy's Instagram story it's
not a yes it's not a no it's a now while
the idol group is getting along the same
can't be said for the fast family
because Tyrese is slamming his co-star
Dwayne Johnson you guys will remember I
told you last month Tyrese commented on
one of Roxas photos then deleted it
asking him to not let a rumored spin-off
of his fast character Agent Hobbs push
back the release date for fast night
well guess what a fast night release
date has been pushed back to April 20 20
year later than it was originally
scheduled Tyrese did not take the news
lightly calling out the rock on
Instagram Thursday claiming the wrestler
turned actor is to blame for the holdup
quote congratulations to the rock and
your brother and long aka seven bucks
producing partner for May
The Fast and the Furious franchise about
you that's right Tyrese claims the rock
is making the fast family about him and
even through shaded weeds will be
Baywatch not doing well at the box
office the rock it's your move man
well another entertainment family who
actually appears to be going strong is
in sync next year is the 20th
anniversary of the boy band and with all
signs pointing to Justin Timberlake
returning to the Super Bowl halftime
today new rumors that he may be joined
by some familiar faces that's right Joey
Fatone hinted at a possible in secret
union at the Super Bowl telling TMZ
sports that if JT is doing it bring him
on someone else and it's right they'll
do it last week a source told et Justin
was close to finalizing a deal to be the
halftime performer adding his former
bandmates would only sweeten the deal
for fans yeah
Beyonce Destiny's Child anybody listen
it wouldn't be the first time they
performed on football's biggest night
anyone else remember in 2001 when they
hit the stage with Aerosmith and Britney
Spears and my old well anyways we know
for a fact Joey isn't the only one
pushing for them to do it again you guys
doing the Super Bowl with eronel and
Britney I think was one of the most for
me it was the best and I definitely
think the most epic it was my ever it
was one of my favorite performances
because Aerosmith is my favorite band so
to be able to do the Super Bowl halftime
show with your favorite band yeah and
then all the sudden you know Nelly in
marriage legalized and Britney pops up
at the end it's it was definitely a
special moment would you guys ever do
that again yes of course
maybe next year February 20 no word
today from Justin's camp and the NFL's
also keeping mum about when we'll get an
official announcement again telling you
t quote we are not going to speculate on
particular artists well listen the Super
Bowl halftime is a spectacle and if
Justin is doing it you got a haven't
seen how epic was it when the boys got
back together for Justin's MTV VMA
performance just a couple years ago
holler at me in the comments section
though because I want to know if you
guys are down for this or not and while
you're at it be sure to subscribe to e
t--'s youtube channel so you don't miss
an episode of the daily Denny and as
always you guys can stick with ET online
for all these stories and a hold
more
[Music]